Speaker 1: All right. Let's go next
to Isaac from Wyoming. Isaac, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hi. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right. I just wanted
to talk about Cynthia Lummis speech.
I know this happened a couple of weeks ago.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So for people who don't know,
let me catch them up if I can. Just
so everybody knows. Cynthia Lummis,
Wyoming senator, spoke at the commencement
ceremony of University of Wyoming.
And she she brought up you know, she was sort of
anti-trans in the speech and we talked about it.
Speaker 2: And you had mentioned in the beginning
of the video that you didn't know why she would
go to a sort of transphobic direction. So I kind
of wanted to just get my opinion on that. Okay.
I think on a national level, it was seen as well
as making a stupid comment. And yes, students
booed when she made the comment about people
denying, quote, scientific facts about there being
two sexes. My thought is this was a well thought
out and calculated scandal. That was a very safe
move for her because these are University of
Wyoming graduates, many of whom are from Wyoming
and will move out of state after graduating.
She's not worried about their vote. Hmm. It's
clear to me that this made this comment knowing it
would score points with her base while undermining
higher education, which I believe the GOP is very
much against, because they don't want the working
class people to be educated. Absolutely.
Speaker 1: That's all true.
Speaker 2: Loomis knew that
it would be controversial and
she would be in headlines and that the largely
uneducated religious base of Wyoming would see it.
So she would score points with her base because
now she's seen as exposing higher education for
brainwashing people into liberal wokeness. Right?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Wyoming is interesting. I've
never been, but I would like to. I mean, how how
rural is your circumstance? Do you live rurally
or in one of the cities?
Speaker 2:
So I live in Albany County, which is where the
University of Wyoming is. And I think because.
It's where the University of Miami is more liberal
type people who tend to move in that and this area
the the other more sort of liberal area of
Wyoming would be around Jackson, which is,
you know, it's all you know you got to
be really wealthy to live in Jackson but.
Speaker 1: But I mean in.
Speaker 2: Terms of.
Speaker 1: How rural it is, you're you're not in
one of these situations where it's like 20 miles
to the grocery store or anything like that.
Speaker 2: No, no, no, no. Like well,
the University of Wyoming is you would
probably consider it like a smaller town,
not not like a large city, but yeah, there's
grocery stores, there's no meeting rooms. The
downtown area, that's really great. And lots
of towns like that. In Wyoming, it's not
close largely. I mean, that is a little bit. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Can you get a good bagel in Wyoming?
Speaker 2: I mean, both supermarkets have bagels.
Speaker 1: Oh, God. Oh, my goodness. Okay. I feel
really bad for you. That is. That's. That's a bad
answer. I mean, you have nothing. You're lying.
Speaker 2: Like blues. Like Einstein.
Speaker 1: Oh, God. Oh, my God. I'm
going to have to let you go, okay?
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: I feel. Wow, Wyoming. I feel
sorry for everybody there. Okay. Thank
you. I appreciate the call. Man, that is that is
disturbing. Your choices are Einstein brothers.
And which actually it's not that bad. Actually,
when I was when I was in Arizona recently, I got
I had no choice. But at the start of a drive,
I picked up an Einstein brothers bagel. It was
I actually wasn't terrible, but. And then
your freezer aisle of supermarket bagels,
that's that's pretty tough. All right,
everybody, thank you to everybody who
called in. We will take more calls next week.
We've got our town hall coming up on June 14th.
And I look forward to talking to more people.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.